the scp foundation employs hundreds of
different procedures in the containment
of the many
many anomalies held in their walls from
hermetically sealed steel boxes to
ordinary observation rooms
it is extremely common for the entities
and containment to attempt
an escape and the foundation has
measures in place to protect against
these breaches and the damage that they
can cause
however there was one scp in containment
that presented an abnormally constant
hazard
it wasn't the entity in captivity though
that created the danger
no it was the constant threat from two
additional creatures that were intent on
getting to the captured entity
and removing it from the foundation's
grasp and they were willing to destroy
anything that got in their way this is
the rather unique
problem with scp-1913
which refers not to a single entity but
to three
one in containment and two that would
stop at nothing
to get to it this is the story of
scp-1913
the strange team made up of agatha telly
and freddie better known as the furies
scp-1913 consists of three separate
entities
referred to as scp-1913-1
scp-1913-2 and scp-1913-3
after the initial discovery of scp-1913
and its containment at an scp foundation
site
the site was attacked by scp-1913-2
and scp-1913-3 it seemed to be an
attempted jailbreak of sorts
with 2 and 3 determined to free one from
captivity at
all costs after this initial attack the
three entities were classified together
as
scp-1913 and their behaviors and fates
were undoubtedly
intertwined whenever scp-1913-and
was taken the other two would follow as
part of scp-1913's containment
procedures
convoy omega-8 also known as the cats in
the cradle was formed
this team run by a team of scientists
that included the young and
woefully inexperienced dr hayward was
tasked with handling the containment
research and movement of scp-1913-1
as well as managing the inevitable
attacks by the other two
entities scp-1913-1 is a ceramic statue
of a cat
20.5 centimeters in height it has the
name agatha written on the bottom
resulting in the entity often being
referred to by that name
it is painted white on the nose ears and
forehead
and has a black ink-like pigment around
its eyes
mouth and paws it has displayed
sentience
and is capable of speech when agatha
talks it has the voice of a young woman
though the statue's mouth does not move
when it speaks
agatha is not friendly toward the
foundation staff
but will answer questions when its
container is shaken
though agatha cannot move on its own it
should be treated with extreme caution
and only touch when absolutely necessary
this is due to the nature of the ink on
its eyes
mouth and paws if it comes into contact
with the skin of a living thing
the ink will soak into its pores the
area touched by the ink will begin to
dissolve and disappear
until the entire body has been dissolved
horrifyingly the affected individual
does not die
until their entire body has dissolved
even if they have lost vital organs
arms and legs left after the head and
torso have dissolved will continue to
move
on their own moving around and grabbing
at objects
the effects of the ink can be stopped if
it is washed off on the skin
before any disillusion can take place
though this will
often still leave scars scp-1913-2 is a
humanoid skeleton covered with dark hair
and ash that has the shape of a human
female
but with a canine looking skull fingers
and toes it is unnaturally fast
capable of reaching speeds up to 65
kilometers per hour
despite lacking any visible muscle
tissue unlike
scp-1913-1 the skeleton does not display
any sentience or capability for speech
it seems to act on orders given by the
other two entities
and attacks anyone wearing a lab coat or
the standard armor
worn by members of the cats in the
cradle it will attack if provoked
and will use its claws to rake at the
victim no matter how
much damage it does scp-1913-2
is incapable of killing its victims and
they continue to live and suffer until
killed by another external force
scp-1913-3 has previously referred
to this entity as telly and that
nickname now appears in official
foundation documentation as well
the final member of this bizarre trio is
scp-1913-3
which refers to itself as freddy freddy
is a creature that shares the appearance
of an adolescent male black labrador
retriever
with one notable difference it does not
have a mouth
a nose or eyes instead its face is made
up of an
array of holes in the shape of a
terrifying grin
emitting a white light freddy is
intelligent
and capable of communication though
refuses to explain its pursuit of agatha
when asked about the subject its only
response is that this
is a family matter when freddie attacks
something it produces a burst of gray
flames from its face holes
these flames have been measured reaching
temperatures up to 1200 degrees
celsius these flames burn non-living
objects in a relatively normal way
but when the fire comes in contact with
a living thing
the flames continue to burn until the
subject's skin has been entirely burnt
away
or until the flame has been deliberately
extinguished
freddy has caused severe burns to
foundation personnel
often resulting in loss of sight hearing
and touch
through unknown means though likely
because of a psychic connection of some
kind
freddie is able to know the location of
telly and agatha
at any given time now that you know the
members of scp-1913 and exactly what
they are capable of
it is time to get into the events of
encounter 0-2-9
most of what we know about the event
comes from the testimony of agent
crowley
who was present for the ordeal he
related the events to dr toki in
interview
1913-providing a glimpse into what
exactly happened according to agent
crowley it was a mistake for dr hayward
to be appointed to a position in the
cats in the cradle
he was too new to the work too green and
something was bound to go wrong
crowley insists that hayward should have
been assigned to a safer group
first in order to build experience and
that what happened to him was not his
fault
the cats in the cradle were transporting
agatha to a new location when they
realized they were running low on
food and fuel they made a stop at site
45-a in order to refresh their stores it
wasn't supposed to take very long
only a few minutes after all they had
made supply runs many times before
and had it down to a science at this
point it had been days since they had
seen freddy or telly however
and the staff was feeling very jumpy it
was too
quiet and after a few days of peace they
had a terrible feeling that something
big was coming
as hayward and crowley drove into site
45's garage
a fireball suddenly erupted behind them
a car had exploded
when the dust cleared there was freddy
and telly the faceless dog
and the skeleton crowley alerted site 45
calling the security team and ordering
them to evacuate the facility of all
personnel immediately
crowley grabbed hayward and attempted to
make it to the roof where they could
evacuate with the rest of the personnel
but before they could make it there they
were intercepted by scps 1913-2
and iii the two men ran into a
laboratory and locked the doors behind
them as freddy and telly attempted to
follow telly began to scratch at the
door with its claws
but when that didn't work freddie
ordered telly to step out of the way
using its flames freddy blew the door
off its hinges
triggering the building's sprinkler
system through the steam and smoke
freddy casually walked into the room
it didn't attack nor did it order telly
to attack
it simply made its way over to crowley
and sat in front of him
crowley asked why it was here why it was
doing this
freddy simply responded that it was
doing this as
a service and that its flame was
redemption
in a moment of panic dr hayward threw a
microscope at freddy
this foolish move only provoked the
entity and it threw
hayward into the counter with a burst of
flames
though hayward was burned the water from
the sprinkler system prevented him from
burning as badly as he could have been
but then freddy ordered telly to kill
hayward for his impudence
telly picked up hayward and threw him
into the far wall of the laboratory
where he crashed into a shelf full of
jars the jars broke open
covering hayward with her contents rocks
of sulfur
tally prepared to charge at hayward but
suddenly
it stopped telly and freddie both
stopped their attack on hayward
regarding the rocks that covered him
with suspicion even
fear crowley quickly put two and two
together and realized that for some
reason these two creatures had an
intense aversion to sulfur gathering
more sulfur from the broken jars he
began pelting the two with pieces of the
rotten smelling mineral
crowley was able to successfully drive
freddie and telly out of the laboratory
and into an area where they could be
finally contained
once and for all crowley then rushed
hayward to the infirmary
where the third degree burns and a
cauterized hole in his chest would need
to be immediately treated
though gravely injured he would
eventually recover from his physical
wounds
his psychological wounds were a
different story though
as agent crowley said i lived to see
those things tear out hayward's heart
and so did he currently all three
entities that make up
scp-19 are in containment at scp
foundation facilities
each entity must be contained at least
1600 kilometers away from the others
each creature is placed in the middle of
a glass ring with a radius of
4 meters and the inside of each glass
ring is filled with sulfur dust
this prevents the entities from reaching
each other and has so far
seemed to prevent freddy from
psychically determining the location of
the other two
anyone handling scp-1913
or agatha must wear latex gloves and
avoid any kind of skin contact at all
times
if skin contact is made for any reason
the affected individual must immediately
wash their hands to remove the ink from
their skin if the ink cannot be removed
the infected staff member must be
terminated any staff entering the room
of scp-1913-2 must remove their lab
coats
and armor in order to avoid provoking it
scp-1913 is in a blast
and fire-proof cell no one is permitted
to enter its containment facility
it is not known for sure what will
happen if the three aspects of scp-1913
are ever allowed to reunite
some have posited that it will result in
the creation of a fourth entity
some believe that agatha will change
shape or transform somehow
some believe that something entirely
different unpredictable
and deadly will happen putting all human
life
at risk we can only hope that we never
have to find out for sure
now go watch scp-3001 red reality
and scp-4205 in the eyes of the beholder
for more explanations of the strangest
tales the scp
foundation has to offer